a trend on Instagram is for women to
make fake podcast Clips have you noticed
this no no on Instagram female
influencers will buy these microphones
and then they'll say something
that's genius yeah yeah it'll be a clip
it'll just be them talking on and
they'll say something like I think that
men should be good providers and too
many women you know insert opinion and
that's the end of the clip and it's got
a million views why do I even do my
whole hour-long podcast why do we do
this Tim let's just make Clips let's
make fake shorts for YouTube oh that's
crazy I think that the older women are
more delusional
well it's like I just think they're
Dumber on myself hold on when you say
older women do you mean older women or
like older women who are single because
that's also two separate categories
right
I mean I'd say the majority of people
that go on the shows are single